if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people I see it
and do whatever we want do we have a
deal
you really sacrifice
thing you almost did
what the hell are you
[Music]
our feet
venom stands alone it has its own
universe to debate and that's that was
already a complete standalone piece and
when I read it I'm quite mercenary and
quite selfish in that aspect I'm very
very happy to have a standalone
character within the Marvel context in
one world but all to myself so I'm kind
of greedy and aspect but at the end of
day that's that's that's kind of above
my paygrade and also it's not my daddy's
tractor so I don't know where it fits it
in the ground schema thing so I would
never rule anything out that being said
again I have to reiterate like the venom
verse and venom is a standalone world
that has been created by um Sony and and
someone else was plenty and abundance to
play with within that world and we've
sort of leaned heavily on the lethal
protector and that sort of so actually
we didn't with a lot of there's a lot of
miles to be had within Venom's world of
its own accord already so who knows
where it leads but it's exciting enough
IP hey everybody it's Charlie they
dropped a new comic-con trailer for
venom with him fighting the other
symbiote and showing some of the things
that it can do they're being kind of
weird about the footage so I have to do
this in a roundabout way but basically
they are confirming that he will be
fighting the other symbiotes because
they've been talking about Lethal
protector so I'll explain how that works
and who's playing that other symbiote
because it was a little bit of confusion
I saw in my Twitter feed but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the comic-con
videos it's just the beginning tomorrow
is gonna be even crazier with trailers
big thing first Tom Hardy talking about
connectedness to spider-man they did
address Tom Holland in the actual
spider-man character as of the MCU from
what Tom Hardy said and from what the
director said in that interview clip
that I put at the beginning and in the
panel itself kind of implied that Tom
Holland is not in the movie unless
they're doing a really clever job of
misleading us so that if he does show up
it's this amazing surprise but Tom Hardy
said he loved to work with Tom Holland
the director said that he would love for
venom to phase spider-man in a movie so
it just implies that there is no actual
spider-man in the movie in Tom Hardy's
saying you know I'm happy to be off by
myself
I'm very selfish in the way that I'm an
actor most actors are pretty
narcissistic so they like all the
attention to be on them but he's also
really pumped up about being part of the
Marvel Universe so they're being kind of
vague about that like it the title card
in the trailer said instead of just
saying
Marvel like most Marvel trailers do it
just says in association with Marvel so
I think that's just them being a little
more technical about how this is
connected to the larger Marvel Universe
he also did not have the spider symbol
on his chest but who knows how they're
gonna handle that and how the symbiote
will look different at the end of the
movie versus the beginning so remember
special effects aren't quite done yet
I'm already made a couple videos about
that is basically the wait-and-see
approach like a venom pans out Tom Hardy
does amazing then I think that later we
might see potential cross over the
footage showed off a whole bunch more
abilities that the symbiote had all
comic-book stuff so if you're a big fan
of venom this won't seem new when he's
walking around in the symbiote they
actually show the symbiote creating a
separate head to talk to him so that
like we as the audience or watching the
symbiote talked to Eddie when in reality
it can do that inside his head too like
during the earlier trailer you see him
walking around not quite sure what's
going on why are you in my head what's
going on later when he goes full
symbiote it's almost like the head grows
out of his neck to talk to him every
once in a while
straight out of the comics you also see
him get in a couple more really big
fights most notably with the other
symbiote that we see during the trailer
now they said that there would be other
villains besides this other big symbiote
but the main villain that he'll be
fighting for most of the movie is the
riot symbiote so there are actually five
derivatives of the Venom symbiote during
the lethal protector storyline they
implied that we might see some of those
other symbiotes but riot is the main one
the trailer made it look like he was
silver but they said that the effects
weren't finished which is probably why
they haven't posted the footage online
yet just because it doesn't look quite
as polished as they want it to the way
they explained the riot symbiote is that
it actually transfers itself to multiple
different people during the movie so you
never know who he's going to be fighting
it could just be like a random person
that he walks by but during the final
big fight like the third act of the film
the final host will be the Carleton
Drake character played by Riz Ahmed the
director was really cool about the other
villains that would pop up you may see
some other big comic book villains I
think he's talking about carnage but
remember the whole idea with that is
that it's sort of a derivative of what
they're doing during the movie so I
don't expect carnage to show up till the
very end you get to see Eddie create all
kinds of weapons with the symbiote just
like in the comics and it's straight-up
carnage carnage is more known for
creating axes
and blades with the symbiotes so that's
why they're just all this stuff pointing
towards carnage appearing later in the
film probably one of the best moments
though like I talked about this I think
in my last big venom video is that the
trailer ends with venom straight-up
biting the head off of a dude there's
also a really big boss battle with him
in the riot symbiote just ripping each
other to shreds
they didn't say much about what's going
on with the other big Marvel characters
they're planning on doing movies for so
like there's Morbius
there's the silk movie that they're
gonna be doing which is a direct
spider-man spin-off and then obviously
the silver and black movie which has
gone back into redevelopment so no idea
how they're gonna tease those within the
venom movie but the director very
pointedly said we're creating a larger
story with this venom movie so that's
basically saying that they're setting up
sequel points if that ends up happening
in the future but on sheer Tom Hardy
performance alone this film will at
least be fun to watch obviously we
haven't seen it yet so we can't really
say but just based on the footage so far
and what Tom Hardy has said about the
character it just seems like it's gonna
be really cool regardless of you know
where it fits in the pantheon of
spider-man films we can rank it against
other spider-man films when it's
released but I don't think it's gonna be
any trouble for him to top that Topher
Grace performance just mega upgrade
there were a couple interviews that they
did where they talked about the movie's
rating the general tone Hardy also
talked about his son bringing him to
this project I mean we wanted to honor
the comics with the movie tonally and as
I think we can all agree venom is one of
the darkest comic book characters and so
it seems appropriate that the movie
would also be dark because we want to do
justice to the true nature of venom
which is a brain-eating alien that
occupies before pushing the envelope and
so it remains we've seen the movies not
rated at the present because they said
that they're still rushing to finish
special effects especially on the
footage that they showed off and the
movies coming out October 5th I'm
expecting a version of this footage to
be online sometime either by the end of
August early September usually when
you're about four weeks away from a
movie is when their marketing blitz
starts and they just start throwing
footage at you left and right so another
spider-man spider verse news if you guys
didn't know they also did a panel for
spider-man into the spider verse where
they showed off more footage confirming
that they're doing the spider-ham care
in addition to just the other universes
we've already learned about a couple of
the other spider-man they're gonna be
showing up but confirmed Jake Johnson's
spider-man that we see during the
trailer is 40 years old during the
events of the movie I think it's pretty
obvious why they made him that old he's
meant to be this tired spider-man like
he's Iron Man in infinity war I'm tired
I'm ready to sort of pass the burden of
leadership on to someone else and go get
married a pepper and go off into the
sunset so if you've read the ultimate
spider-man comic book with Miles Morales
then you know that he dies that's what
serves as inspiration for miles to take
the spider-man mantle but obviously this
is a movie intended for younger
audiences in the trailers imply that
there's a pretty sizable chunk of it
that he actually spends training the
miles character before probably ends up
dying then miles probably has to team up
with the other spider-man from the
multiverse to take down Green Goblin in
any of the other villains in the film
unless the movie tanks that is also very
definitely gonna be getting a sequel it
just feels like there's too much
material to not do a sequel so it just
all depends on how well it does at the
box office but do not forget tomorrow
Aquaman trailer maybe some Shazam
footage will post online maybe some
Wonder Woman behind the scenes and then
all the DC TV trailers so it's gonna be
crazy
leave all your requests in the comments
below click here for that brand new
Young Justice season 3 trailer and click
here for brand new Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]